What's up?
Saw Les Mis, I take it?
I did.
And?
What didn't you like?
Well, considering that it started yesterday
and I'm just getting home, I'm gonna go with
'It's too f*cking long,' for starters.
I'm starting to think you have an attention
span problem.
I'm sorry if my attention span can only tolerate
17 Hugh Jackman songs before it gives up.
Dude, it could have been a lot longer, they
didn't even shoot the whole play.
'It could have been longer' is not a defense
against the criticism of 'It was too long.'
Okay, so what else didn't you like about it.
What about the speak-singing?
Speak-singing?
You know, how they don't say any lines of
dialogue.
Everything is sung, when they're speaking
Even if they're only saying hi.
It's a musical--
It's really f*cking stupid and it made me
really angry and it made me want to punch
them in the eye.
You are a good songwriter, that's for sure.
They turn every line of dialoge into a song.
It's freaking dumb.
That's what musicals do.
That's what--
I need some milk my cereal is dry, could you
pass the milk-
You don't have any cereal
-to me.
What else didn't you like?
Alright, well, what's Russell Crowe doing
in this movie, and why does he sing like he
has to poop?
Come on, he's not that bad.
No, he's terrible.
Another problem, not enough sex.
This movie has a sex scene!
Yeah, with Anne Hatheway.
Right.
Listen, I only go to see Anne Hatheway movies
for two reasons: to see her naked.
That's not--
Boobies, I need those boobies.
Very mature.
When I go to the movies.
I don't even know why I bother talking with
you about movies because you--
Boobies.
Are you done?
Okay, I'm done now.
Why don't we talk about some of the--
What about the riot in the streets?
Why does it have to feel so small?
What do you mean 'small?'
The movie makes you feel like it's some sort
of historical trigger event, but it's just
a bunch of teenagers that had too much beer
hiding out behind some chairs in an alley.
Why don't we talk about some of the positive
qualities of the movie--
There are none!
There are none.
This conversation is over.
You can't just end a conversation because
you--
Les Mis, Les Mis, the movie all in song.
Les Mis, Les Mis, it's f*cking 5 hours long.